[Music]
beyond those of us who react with
pleasant surprise when earning a trophy
there are gamers who are hardcore
achievement hunters now with you belong
to that group or not there are certain
bragging rights associated with earning
achievements that are particularly
tricky I've got five lined up for you
that an eye on impossible open-world
zombie game Dead Rising isn't a walk in
the park by anyone's books but the ante
is seriously upped when you try and
attempt to be seven-day survivor
challenge this achievement will require
you to survive through the seven-day
infinity mode more level brimming with
zombies you won't be able to save if you
want to cross this one off so look
forward to settling in for seven full
in-game days which equates to about 14
real-time hours you'll definitely want
to either bring a friend all steal
yourself beforehand if you have a mind
to take this one on fortunately if
people short there's also a five day
survivor achievement to be earned as you
can imagine the rhythm genre has some
pretty challenging skill based
achievements but this next one is
probably the most cruel Guitar Hero
maybe the rhythm game with the infamous
in human achievement which requires you
to nail thousands of notes in Dragon
forces through the fire and the flames
but rock band two's ultimate prize was
the bladder of Steel achievement if
you're curious as to whether I'm running
with a theme here I definitely am this
particular achievement calls for the
gamer to play through the seven our
endless setlist - without pausing or
failing a song basically charge your
batteries both biological and electrical
before attempting this one
the Stanley parable is known for having
some easy achievements including
clicking on a certain door five times as
well as some better a whole lot harder
including my personal favorite entitled
commitment
while some gamers prefer the sound of
the go outside achievements that calls
for you to keep the game on your system
but not play it for five years
commitment calls the game is - and I
quote play the Stanley parable for 24
hours during Tuesday if your primary
school math hasn't failed even yes that
does require you to play the game for
the entirety of Tuesday oddly specific
and according to steam only 1.1 percent
of all players had actually earned it
I'm gonna have a Captain Obvious moment
here and tell you that Super Meat Boy is
a really hard game obviously then
playing for achievements makes it even
harder well there are a lot of
achievements to earn by not dying
throughout the games various levels the
hardest of them all is called impossible
boy impossible boy calls for you to
complete the cotton alley dark world
without dying
cotton alley is the final and most
difficult chapter and dark worlds upped
the ante to make the game especially
difficult as if it wasn't already
watching youtubers meet this challenge
head-on is an epic incredibly impressive
and wildly stressful thing to behold
I would definitely recommend it finally
I have an achievement that not only
calls for the endurance required to beat
rock band two's bladder of Steel
achievement but also a hell of a lot of
time and skill I'm talking Gears of War
3
seriously 3.0 seriously 3.0 is an
achievement that you'd probably only
consider trying for if you're really
into Gears of War 3 I mean really really
into it this achievement is the
follow-up to Gears of War 2 seriously
2.0 challenge which was widely believed
to be one of the hardest achievements to
attain in
of videogames well 3.0 is what - on this
one you have to hit level 100 and earn
all of the 65 onyx medals in the game
getting those medals includes faced like
achieving the highest tier above goals
getting 6000 pistol kills earning 5
million bucks in horde mode and
finishing beast mode at insane
difficulty each feat like the ones I've
mentioned will only earn you one medal
of peace and there are 62 more justice
demanding to collect before you can earn
seriously 3.0 it's enough to make you
nervous over what on earth seriously 4.0
is going to look like when please all
launches but for those who've earned it
at least you have those 100 points
towards your gamer score to keep you
warm at night let me know down in that
comment box what's the hardest
achievement that you've ever earned I
look forward to reading about all your
victories and I will catch you again
next week